i'd like to review some popular music so  i went to the billboard charts sure  enough i found  the latest song from my favorite artist  lil baby  big fan of his for years now and this  one featuring 42  doug another musician who i find speaks  to me on a very deep level  we paid  stop right there for just a moment  because you know riding on the window of  a car  is not generally advised and doing it  while holding a wad of cash is also  it seems like a disaster waiting to  happen frankly are they going to the  bank is he going to deposit it in a  savings account if so  that's responsible that's good but just  keep the cash on the inside of the  vehicle  until you get to the bank to make the  transaction  excuse my friends don't like no okay i i  did just pick up there where he said  excuse my french  is he actually speaking french because i  i can't understand  anything that's being said